[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pas qu'on aille faire des choses en
action mais tu es enceinte c'est pas
grave tu es sûr bah oui bâti match match
terne
lee
excuse moi
m
[Musique]
alors c'est a fini d'installer la
signalisation si loin exactement parce
que ça le croisement dangereux de toute
la région je ne peux meurtrier je sais
moi je me un temple à dire que comme ça
le croisement et les tests les uns y
voient là je vous dire que tu as un jour
un accident c'est vraiment que je me
fais mon boulot je reprends donc il peut
rien se laisser voler vers un lac autour
des tables pour vous avec les gens ils
vont
jeter sur le côté là t'as permis
mais sylvain je perds tu l'aimé ou qu'on
stoppe exactement il est peut-être
encore le coffre de la voiture
merde à ma merde
ouah
j'espère que vous allez bien aujourd'hui
et j'ai une jolie peau comme vous a vu
quand sade et voilà je me fais des
massages
érotiques
là je vais mourir de mort lente
il va manger
[Musique]
et j'ai pourtant